ؤلاء الرجال لا يزالون كذلك في ضفه الاباء
ضفه العياش يشتبكون مع جنود الاحتلال رغم
رغم استهدافه للمخيمات والبلدات والمدن
والقرى خاصه مخيمات جنين وطولكرم واستهداف
المدنيين وتخريب البنيه التحتيه وما عمليه
التسلسل التسلل وما عمليه التسلل
لمستوطنين الا مرار لطوفان الاقصى باذن
الله سبحانه
وتعالى لقد مني هذا العدو بخساره
استراتيجيه يوم السابع من اكتوبر وستظل
هذه الخساره وصمه في وجهه وفي جبينه
ويلاحقه من بعدها الفشل تلو الفشل كلما
امعن في عدوانه ضد قطاعنا الابي عسكريا
وسياسيا اعلاميا وحقوقيا اخلاقيا
وانسانيا لقد فشل شعبنا الصابر المرابط
ومقاومتنا المضفره في قطاع غزه كل مخططات
التهجير والتغييب وتصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وستفشل مخططاتهم العدوانيه
التي يتحدثون عنها بين الفينه والاخرى
وسيحقق شعبنا ومقاومتنا نصرا مبينا في
معركه طوفان الاقصى باذن الله ولاول مره
في تاريخ هذا الكيان يمثل في محكمه العدل
الدوليه ليحاكم امام العالم اجمع على
جرائم التطهير العرقيه وحرب الاباده ضد
شعبنا ساركز الحديث اليوم في ثلاثه محاور
مرتبطه ارتباطا موضوعيا بما يجري من
مداولات في محكمه العد الدوليه بمدينه
لهاي في هولندا يومي الخميس
والجمعه الماضيين الحادي عشر والثاني عشر
من كانون الثاني يناير
2024 اولا حول موقع طوفان الاقصى في مسار
نضال شعبنا من اجل الحريه
والاستقلال نود ان نعيد التوضيح والتاكيد
لابناء شعبنا اولا ثم لامتنا لاحرار
العالم بل العالم باسره حقيقه ما جرى يوم
السابع من اكتوبر ولماذا كان وما هو سياقه
المرتبط بالقضيه الفلسطينيه كقضيه وطنيه
وضحى زيف المزاعم الصهيونيه ووضع الحقائق
في نصابها
الصحيح ان معركه الشعب الفلسطيني مع
الاحتلال والاستعمار لم تبدا يوم السابع
من اكتوبر عام 2023 الماضي وانما بدات قبل
ذلك ب 100 عام وخمسه
اعوام منذ ان وطات اقدام الاحتلال
البريطاني ارض فلسطين عام
1917 30 عاما من الاستعمار
البريطاني
و75 عاما من الاحتلال
الصهيوني عانى شعبنا طوال هذه العقود
العشره وتزيد من كافه اشكال القهر والظلم
ومصادره الحقوق الاساسيه ومن سياسات الفصل
العنصري وعانى قطاع غزه كذلك حصارا خانقا
مستمرا منذ اكثر من 17 عاما ليتحول الى
اكبر سجن مفتوح في الع
العالم لقد تم توثيق انتهاكات الاحتلال
الصهيوني وفضائح بحق شعبنا وارضنا
ومقدساتنا من قبل مؤسسات الامم المتحده
ولجان التحقيق والمحاكم الدوليه ومنظمات
حقوق الانسان العالميه بل حتى بعض منظمات
اسرائيليه وقد مر ذلك كله وما زال يمر دون
مسائله او محاسبه او اجراء بحق هذا الك
ككيان الغاصب
لفلسطين لقد تعاملت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحلفاؤها الغربيون مع الكيان
الصهيوني منذ انشائه كدوله فوق القانون
ولا زالوا يوفرون الغطاء اللازم لاستمرار
احتلالها ومصادره المزيد من ارضنا وانتهاك
مقدساتنا والاعتداء عليها وتهويدها وفرض
ظروف معيشيه قاسيه وبيئات كما يقولون
طارده لتهجير شعبنا فضلا عن محاولاتهم
المستمره لتهجير الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل
قسري واجباره على الرحيل عن ارضه
ووطنه لقد اكد المسؤولون الاسرائيليون
رفضهم القطعيه لقيام دوله
فلسطينيه وللتذكير فقبل شهر من طوفان
الاقصى حمل رئيس الوزراء حمل رئيس الوزراء
الصهيوني
نتنياهو وهو هو يلقي خطابه في الامم
المتحده في سبتمبر
2023 حمل خريطه كامله لفلسطين التاريخيه
بما فيها الضفه وقطاع غزه والقدس وقد لونت
كلها بعلم او بلون
واحد وكتب عليها اسرائيل ولم يحرك العالم
ساكنا امام مثل هذا التصرف وهو يرى عن
جيته واستهتاره بالمجتمع الدولي القانون
الدولي
كذلك الان وبعد اكثر من 75 عاما من
الاحتلال والمعاناه وافشال اي امل لشعبنا
بالتحرير وتقرير المصير والاستقلال
والعوده نتساءل هل كان المطلوب من شعبنا
ان يواصل الانتظار ام ان الواجب الوطنيه
والرد الطبيعيه على كل تلك الممارسات وكل
ذلك العدوان هو مبادره شعبنا للدفاع عن
ارضه وحقوقه ومقدس سه لقد كانت عمليه
طوفان الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر خطوه
ضروريه واستجابه طبيعيه في اطار العمل من
اجل تخليص شعبنا من الاحتلال واستعاده
الحقوق وانجاز الاستقلال والحريه كباقي
شعوب هذا العالم ومواجهه ما يحاك من
مخططات صهيونيه تستهدف تصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه والسيطره على الارض وحسم
السياده على
المقدسات ثانيا حول اصرار ومواصله
الاحتلال والاداره الامريكيه في تسويق
روايات كاذبه ودعايات مضلله ضد مقاومه
شعبنا المشروعه رغم انه ثبت للعالم زيفها
وبطلانها لقد استهدفت عمليه طوفان الاقصى
في السابع من اكتوبر تشرين اول الماضي
المواقع العسكريه الصهيون
المحيطه بقطاع غزه
ونجحت المقاومه في تحقيق اهدافها وهدفها
الاساس في تدمير فرقه غزه وايقاع جنودها
بين قتيل وجريح كما تم اسر عدد من جنود
العدو ومقاتليه فيما لم يستهدف اي من
المدنيين ان تجنب استهداف المدنيين وخصوصا
النساء والاطفال وكبار السن هو التزام
ديني اخلاقي وان مقاومتنا ورجالها منضبط
بضوابط وتعاليم وقيم ديننا الاسلامي
الحنيف وان استهدافنا هو لجنود الاحتلال
ومن يحملون السلاح ضد شعبنا وهو ما كان
واضحا وصريحا في خطاب الاخ المجاهد محمد
الضيف ابو خالد حفظه الله في الدقائق
الاولى من العمليه لقد تعاملت بعد ذلك
حركه حماس بايجابيه مع ملف المدنيين الذين
تم احضارهم الى قطاع غزه وسعت منذ اليوم
الاول لاطلاق سراحهم بالسرعه الممكنه وهو
ما حدث فعلا بعد مماطله من حكومه نتنياهو
خلال هدنه انسانيه امتدت لسبعه ايام انما
يروجه الاحتلال ويسوقه الاعلام الامريكي
والغربي المنحاز لروايه الاحتلال حول
استهداف كتائب القسام للمدنيين يوم السابع
من تشرين اول اكتوبر الماضي هو محض افتراء
وكذب وما يحاول الاحتلال ترديده حول وجود
مصادر للمعلومات ينسب اليها هذا الكلام هو
روايات واكاذيب اسرائيليه صادره عن جهات
تتولى الدعايه السوداء المضلله لصالح
اهداف الاحتلال ولا توجد اي مصادر مستقله
تؤكد صحه هذه المزاعم او حتى شيئا منها ان
تلك المزاعم بقتل حركه حماس المدنيين قد
ثبت كذبها في تقارير صحفيه نشرت في
الاعلام الصهيوني حيث اثبتت بان قتل
المدنيين
الاسرائيليين سقطوا نتيجه قصف طائرات
الاباش الاسرائيليه للمشاركين في مهرجان
نوفا قرب
مستوطنه رعيم كما اكدت شهادات اسرائيليه
اخرى ان غارات الجيش جيش الاحتلال
هي التي تسببت بقتل عدد كبير من
المستوطنين تم تجميعهم في مستوطنات غلاف
غزه لاسباب
عمليات حيث قام الطيران والمدفعيه
والدبابات الصهيونيه بتدمير المنازل اثناء
الاشتباكات مع المقاومه يوم السابع من
اكتوبر والايام التي تلته ما تسبب بقتل
الكثيرين منهم وذلك ضمن سياسه وبروتوكول
هانيبال الاسرائيلي الذي يمنح قاده
الميدان فرصه قتل الاسير على ان يظل حيا
اسيرا عند
المقاومه كما ان مزاعم الاحتلال حول قتل
الاطفال واغتصاب النساء ما هي الا دعايه
اسرائيليه كشف كذبها من اجل التحريض على
مقاومتنا وقد ثبت ذلك من خلال التحقيقات
العمليه العلميه لجهات
محايده تبعت بالتفصيل كل هذه الادعاءات
وفندت كاشفه زيفها وكذبها واستنادا على كل
ما سبق نؤكد للعالم ان القتلى الوحشي
للمدنيين خصوصا من النساء والاطفال يقع
بحق ابناء شعبنا على مدار 100 يوم من
العدوان النازي على قطاع غزه وان هذا
العدوان هو سلوك منهجي للكيان الصهيوني
يتعمد من خلاله اذلال وتهجير شعب باكمله
وان نحو
24000 من الشهداء بينهم 100 الا طفل و7000
امراه و60000 من الجرحى والمصابين
و8000 من المفقودين يكشف كل ذلك حقيقه هذا
الاحتلال النازي القائم على جرائم القتل
والتهجير القسري في اطار جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه التي ينفذها في قطاع غزه الان
وفي هذا السياق نجدد التاكيد على ان اولئك
المدافعين عن التوحش الصهيوني لا تعنيهم
القراءه الموضوعيه للاحداث ولا حجم
الخسائر والضحايا فهم دوما يتبنون روايه
الاحتلال ومن ثم يذهبون لتبرير جرائمه
الوحشيه في سياسه الكيل بمكيالين عندما
يتعلق الامر بادانه وتجريم الكيان
الصهيوني بل ربما احيانا تبني الجريمه
والدفاع عنها وهنا نقول اننا على ثقه بان
اي تحقيقات نزيهه وموضوعيه ومستقله سوف
تؤكد صدق روايتنا وكذب مزاعم الاحتلال
الذي اثبتت كل المعطيات والوقائع والاحداث
خلال العدوان على قطاع غزه ممارسته كل
اساليب الكذب والخداع والتضليل والدعايه
السوداء ثالثا حول جلسات الاستماع في
محكمه العدل الدوليه يومي الخميس والجمعه
الماضيين الحادي ع والثاني عشر كانون ثاني
يناير
2024 اننا اذ نثمن ونقدر عاليا ما قامت به
دوله جنوب افريقيا برفعها هذه القضيه امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه ضد الاحتلال ف ونقدر
كذلك الجهد الذي بذله فريقها القانوني وما
قدمه من حجج وادله وبراهيم موثقه نرى ان
ذلك يثبت للعالم اجمع تورط الاحتلال
الصهيوني في ارتكاب جرائم الاباده
الجماعيه والتطهير العرقيه في قطاع غزه
وان ما تضمنته هذه المرافعه يوم امس الاول
من حجج
وادله تمثل سببا وجيها ومعتبرا لوقف
العدوان على شعبنا في قطاع غزه فورا ووقف
قتل المدنيين الاطفال والنساء ومن
ثم البد في محاكمه الاحتلال على جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه التي ترتكب ضد شعبنا
الفلسطيني وفي هذا السياق فاننا واذ نرحب
بمواقف الدول الشقيقه والصديقه التي اعلنت
تاييدها لجنوب افريقيا في مسار وقف
العدوان على شعبنا ومحاكمه الاحتلال على
جرائمه فاننا نجدد دعوتنا لكل الدول الى
الانضمام رسميه للدعوه التي قدمتها دوله
جنوب
افريقيا لقد فشل الاحتلال الصهيوني فشلا
ذريعا في الرد على ما طرح من طرف الادعاء
وفي مواجهه الحقائق والادله الدامغه التي
عرضها الفريق القانوني لجنوب افريقيا امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه تلك الادله التي تفضح
وتعري جرائمه الممنهجه في القتل والاباده
الجماعيه وفي التهجير القصري كما يعمق
انهزامه امام عداله قضيتنا ومشروعيه
حقوقنا ونضالنا من اجل
الحريه
والاستقلال وبدل الاقرار
بجريمته وعلاوه على فشله في تقديم اي دفاع
منطقي عن هذه الجريمه كان كل ما قاله في
مرافعته محامي دفاع الكيان الصهيوني هو
اقرار ضمني باستهداف شعبنا بجريمه اباده
جماعيه بل كان من الوقاحه لدرجه انه يمكن
تلخيص مرافعته بجمله واحده لم نفعل واذا
فعلنا فمن حقنا ان نفعل ذلك اننا نتطلع مع
شعبنا وامتنا وكل حر في هذا العالم ان
تصدر محكمه العدل الدوليه وبشكل عاجل
قرارا تاريخيا ينصف ضحايا شعبنا في قطاع
غزه وذلك بوقف العدوان فورا واغاثه اهلنا
وتضميد جراحته ومحاسبه قاده الكيان
الصهيوني كمجرمي
حرب في المواقف الدوليه من هذه القضيه ان
موقف الاداره الامريكيه وبعض الدول
الغربيه من دعوه جنوب افريقيا ضد الكيان
الصهيوني بانها لا اساس لها كما ادعى
بعضهم يثبت مجددا الانحياز الكامله
للاحتلال وانخراطه الفعليه في جرائم باده
والتهجير ضد اهلنا في قطاع غزه وهي كذلك
محاوله لتعطيل ادوات العداله الدوليه في
وقف العدوان وتجريم
الاحتلال اننا كذلك ندين القصف الجويه
والبحريه والاعتداء الهمجيه على اليمن
الشقيق فهو جريمه وعدوان سافر على السياده
اليمنيه وهو تهديد لامن المنطقه التي تشهد
عسكره امريكيه بريطانيه جاءت لحمايه
الاحتلال الصهيوني النازي وللتغطية
بل وكل دول العالم التي باتت تضيق ذرعا
الى حد الاختناق بهذه السياسات العدوانيه
الامريكيه وهي بكل تاكيد لن تقف مكتوفه
اليدين امام الجرائم الصهيونيه الوحشيه
وحرب الاباده الجماعيه التي يتعرض لها
شعبنا الفلسطيني الرحمه للشهداء شهداء
شعبنا ومقاومتنا ومقاومه امتنا على طريق
تحرير القدس والشفاء للجرحى والمرضى
والحريه للاسرى والمعتقلين والنصر لشعبنا
ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد
وشكرا